i'm going to talk about space jam and
then
we'll see what the article has to say
page 9 if you want to go to it
uh and then we'll uh we'll we'll cover
that and you said by the way tom you
said you've seen it as well
i have not seen it you have not seen it
okay lebron james sends message to
haters as space jam takes over box
office it's a new york post story
lebron james sent a message to the world
as his new film takes over the box
office james took to twitter to link an
article stating
a space jump a new legacy is set to
finish the weekend at number one with a
projected 32 million dollars opening
beating up black widow hi haters
james world cup can you pull up this
twitter tweet please hi haters the
sequel to 1996 michael jordan let's
space jam pulled in more than 13 million
on friday despite poor reviews the movie
which reportedly cost 150 million
dollars to make is also available on hbo
max
other hoop stars who appear in the space
jam sequel include anthony davis damian
lillard
diana tarusi and klay thompson so
having said that gerard you watched it
last night tell us about it
space jam the original space channels
are my favorite movies and in fairness
i'm not a lebron james fan but i thought
okay
listen it's a kid's movie they can they
can
polish his image right and all this
thing was the first 15 minutes were the
most
self-aggrandizing arrogant thing i've
ever seen in my life juxtaposed it
against the original space jam
where the first 10 minutes 15 minutes
were michael jordan joking about himself
it was self-deprecating right there just
the self-awareness
of what you need to know lebron james
being called king and
you know showing why he's the greatest
thing in the world you know versus
michael jordan cracking on himself
right off the bat that's all you need to
know about about the two guys and
the way that they maintain their brand
but i watched it i got all the way
through it
and it had some unbelievably talented
people don cheadle
ryan coogler the the animation was was
terrific
there was like seven jokes and i i sat
there
after you know an hour and a half and i
felt like i was in like some sort of
mental gulag i have no idea why i did
this
90 minutes of my life on this and i said
you know i i'm not
positive if this is true but
i think i can make an argument that
casey anthony is a better mother
than space jam is a movie i think i'm
not
positive i didn't care for it i'm not
i'm not i'm not really
in the the you know i don't want i don't
like ripping other artists and stuff
like that man and you know 150 million
dollars some unbelievable guys
that's great but this was the single
worst thing i think i've ever this was
the room bad this was oh high mark level
bad this was oh man i i don't even like
this should be this should be classified
as a war crime this thing was horrible
how they're showing this to children
that's bad to you oh my god
now gerard doesn't have children right
so it's not like you were sitting there
with a couple kids that might have
dug it so you have any thoughts on it i
have some thoughts on it number one i
think this is all spin
right i think i think lebron can come
out hey haters scoreboard but you know
what if this was a normal times
that's not a good debut 32 million is
not a good friday through sunday debut
as a matter of fact
it's right up there with robert downey
jr's doolittle all right they did he did
the exact same damn thing
in 2020 and that was considered one of
the probably the biggest flop of
downey's career
so a you have limited releases right now
okay
there's just not that many movies
there's not that many options out there
b you know if you compare it to what
michael debuted with what
jerry maguire was out at that time i
mean there were some big big movies and
some competition i give lebron credit
shows up at the finals with his own
bottle of tequila that he's promoting
and he's got the movie if he was in the
finals this thing would have done even
better right because that's a
a running commercial that was the plan
though if you look at the date when it
came out exactly
was he would be in the finals yeah so i
think i think this is a little bit of a
disappointment but all in all it's going
to do well
it's going to do a couple hundred
million worldwide especially when you
bring in the streaming numbers he just
doesn't know how to have fun he's like
the least fun human being like the dude
is a-rod man like he's like so image
conscious he's just
everything comes off as so canned you
were right i felt like i was watching
lebron james propaganda
this was not so a fun movie so here's
what happened with me kai go back to the
tweet that i sent to you like go go to
that
so here's what i said i responded back
to him i said jordan versus lebron space
jam space jam one mj budget 80 million
box office 250.2 million
in 1997 not including inflation no
streaming no social media space jam 2
budget 150 box office it would need to
do 471 million dollars to match space
jam
one no hater here just simple data right
that's what i respond okay so now
two hours after this tweet goes out i
take the kiss to go watch it
so it's uh myself and the kids and mario
and carol so we go to watch to we'll go
to watch the
the what do you call it the movie and
for me the first 15 minutes
just look pretty much what you said it
looked like a documentary it didn't let
him look like a movie it looked like how
great he is his highlight reel
all that stuff right and then the story
starts and it's the story of father
son and you know he's forced him to be a
basketball player this guy's a gamer and
you know hey
i i saw that part the emotional
connection about a father trying to get
his kids to be like him
it's a very difficult position it's
lebron james this guy
is the greatest basketball player in the
world as of three years ago right i mean
he's changed the last two or three years
the greatest basketball player around
the world so the storyline was great so
i asked my kids afterwards not gonna lie
to the last 45 minutes i was knocked out
it was the best sleep i had in a long
time
i'm not not to take shots at the movie
just so everybody knows i knock out
fifty percent of movies i watch
this is not like it's a space champ
thing it's a pbd what's the theater fall
shout out to jp series theater was not
only full they clapped at the end people
stood up screaming they loved the
storyline okay
i asked my kids what do you think about
it they like space jam two more than one
but they don't know like the whole
history and all this other stuff they
don't look at it from that standpoint
my boys related to the story that has to
do with them and their father
that's all they talked about because my
son says he wants to be a scientist
so he's not trying to be and i always
tell him buddy i don't want you to do
what your daddy does what do you want to
do right so to them
it was kind of like that connection they
made with the story i thought the story
was
phenomenal is what the story was the
writer is an armenian writer by the way
the guy who wrote the script as an
armenian right i thought the script was
great
i thought don was freaking insane he's
done cheating he just crushed it
i thought lebron is not an actor i
thought lebron's commercials the first
year he came out were better than the
acting he did in this movie
uh and then at the same time there's
just a part of me that you know
i go back and i think about a couple
things here again
high haters numbers here i mean what
what what do you
buddy first of all michael wouldn't do
that here's the other part here's the
other part
if i'm lebron james why didn't kobe
bryant ever do space jam too
mm-hmm why why what are you doing space
jam too
yeah like what is the idea of doing
space jam 2
i don't even if i'm his market or if i'm
his right hand guy
and i'm sitting there saying nothing
about your brand has ever been linked to
michael jordan
kobe's was kobe was trying to be like
mike kobe is the gatorade commercial
like mike i want to be like mike i want
to be out you know the whole thing yes
kobe was trying to be mine there's
nothing about lebron james that's like
he's trying to be michael other than the
number
not his game not no well it used to be
six until michael said you know he took
a shot at lebron saying no one is bigger
than the nba and michael j lebron's like
i'll take 23 right now lebron
do your own movie what's space champ so
i don't understand that concept like
are we supposed to expect giannis to do
space jam 3 in about 10 years
i don't know what i think my i think
lebron secretly thought he was going to
do a better movie than michael i think
he wanted to one-up him
and i think that was dangerous you know
by the way they're also tooting their
horn about
like i said this is all spin you know
with movie numbers that's all it is
they were coming out and saying we beat
black widow well black widow's been out
for three weeks and it did 80 million on
their first weekend yeah right so
there's no comparison there whatsoever i
will give lebron
credit for one thing it's not easy
acting on a green screen and
with animated characters i mean if
you're not a trained actor and then you
have to try to pull that out off and
make it seem real i'm going to go check
it out dash wants to see it
either was mike by the way neither was
mike was yeah michael with ryan coogler
advising you and
150 million on the on the warner lot you
don't think it's uh
something you could pull off no i'm
sorry i'm sure if he can but i'm just
saying it's not the easiest
if you're watching this who watched it
if you watched it
did you like it did you not like it just
out of curiosity
you know if you if you if you've seen it
and you liked it put thumbs up
if you watched it and you didn't like it
put thumbs down maybe give us a score
out of 10 rotten tomatoes i think's got
a 4-2 or 4-3 i don't know what the score
is
yeah imdb is a 4-3 here this thing of
ours just posted 4-3 on imdb
what's your score out of 10 if you
actually watch it and right next to it
write down i'm a lebron james fan or i'm
not a lebron james fan
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye